Hola hola, bienvenidos.
Veamos términos semejantes.
Digamos que yo tengo dos Chuck Norris y bueno,
lo que vamos a hacer es sumarle otros
tres Chuck Norris.
Entonces, esto puede parecer un tanto obvio para ti...
aquí saco a Chuck...
ahí está...
¿Cuántos Chucks tengo ahora?...
¿cuántos Chucks tengo ahora?
Esto...
esto puede representarse literalmente como 1 Chuck,
aquí lo saco, ahí está...
y otro, así que más otro Chuck Norris...
ahora, también de este otro lado,
esto te puede ser 2 por Chuck Norris,
de este otro lado tenemos entonces a 3,
tenemos 1 Chuck Norris más otro Chuck y más Chuck,
ahora bien...
ahhh bueno, ¿cuál es el total?
¿qué total tenemos?
Tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
aquí sumados 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 Chuck Norris,
así que esto es igual...
finalmente esto es igual a 5 Chuck Norris.
Ahora, nos pondremos un poco más abstractos
aquí, vamos a usar un poco de lo que es la
notación tradicional en el álgebra,
así que si yo tengo...
si yo tengo "2x"...
"2x", entonces recuerda que "2x" puedes verlo
como "2x" o 2 por "x" y a eso le voy a agregar "3x"...
más "3x"
¿cuántas "x" tengo ahora?
Una vez más tenemos 2 "x", lo puedes ver
como una "x" más otra "x" y no conocemos
el valor de "x", pero cualquiera sea este
se puede agregar a él mismo, así que "3x",
será lo mismo que...
haré lo mismo acá en color verde...
es "x" más "x" más "x",
entonces ¿cuántas "x" tenemos finalmente?
Las cuento son... son...
aquí es un más, aquí e s 1, 2, 3, 4, 5...
"5x", así que esto es igual, esta suma es "5x"...
"5x" ahí está...
y pensemos en esto por un segundo, todo esto,
todo lo que realmente hice fue sumar estos
dos número que están multiplicando la "x",
estos dos números el 2 y el 3 son llamados
coeficientes, una palabra algo elegante, pero
simplemente se refiere a estos números, a
estas constantes que están multiplicando a la variable.
Sumas el 2 y el 3 y obtienes "5x", entonces pensemos en esto un poco más, vayamos a la expresión de arriba.
Tenemos 2 Chucks más 3 Chucks, digamos que...
que a esto le agregamos... le agregamos...
¿qué te parece, 7 ciruelas?
Así que 7 y aquí dibujo la ciruela...
ahí está...
entonces tenemos 7 ciruelas más 2 Chucks
más 3 Chucks más otras 2 ciruelas...
otras 2 ciruelas ahí están.
Así que, ¿a qué será igual todo esto?
No agregaría yo el 7 y el 2 más el 3 más
el otro 2, porque estamos agregando cosas
diferentes aquí, tenemos 2 Chucks más 3
Chucks, eso aún se va a simplificar a 5 Chucks.
Luego por separado pensaríamos en las ciruelas,
tenemos 7 ciruelas más otras 2 ciruelas,
en total son 9 ciruelas.
Y similarmente por este... por este otro lado,
si yo tengo en lugar de... en lugar de solo
tener "2x" más "3x" tengo... tengo 7... "7y"
más el "2x" más el "3x" más "2y", aquí,
¿qué tengo ahora?
No puedo agregar las "x" con las "y", porque
pueden ser cosas distintas, lo que puedo hacer
es agregar las "x", obtengo "5x" y después
por otro lado por separado, tengo... tengo
"7y" y le sumo el "2y", entonces en total
"9y", así que aquí tengo más "9y", así...
bueno son 7 y 2 de la misma cosa, en total
tengo 9 de la misma cosa.
Aquí agrego en éste, esto más esto,
es esto y por este otro lado, agrego estos 2
y obtengo el "5x".
Ojalá tenga sentido lo que estoy diciendo
aquí, espero... espero lo esté diciendo bien.
Daré, daré otro ejemplo.
Si yo tengo "2x" más 1 más "7x" más 5,
¿qué pasaría?
Si tal vez, tal vez tú quieras sumar el 2
y el 1, pero no porque son cosas distintas,
aquí simplemente es el número 1, entonces
tenemos "2x" más "7x", esto es igual a "9x"... "9x"
y ahora sumamos el número 1 y el número 5,
1 más 5 es igual a 6 y terminamos.
Nos vemos pronto.